people watching you do this tour bring
this movie to everybody around the world
and reception has been phenomenal
dessert already feel like validation of
the 15 years of hard work and passion
you put into this it does yeah thank you
for asking that I appreciate it 15 long
years man I've been fighting for this
one fighting hard uh to make this movie
to keep this movie on track I believed
in it 10 years ago the studio had asked
me and they were under different
leadership back then but they said hey
aside aside from Black Adam is there any
other characters in the DC Universe you
might want to play and I said no I
really appreciate it but no it's got to
be Black Adam and here we are 15 years
later so to answer your question
directly uh
the fans who are seeing the movie now we
had thousands watch it last night at our
Global Premiere they love the movie like
you said that's the validation and man
and that feels good it really does now
with the JSA being a pivotal Port of
this that gives you a lot of characters
to play with moving forward right who of
your famous co-stars you've worked with
or even actors you've been wanting to to
work with your whole career would you
love to see jump on board with you and
at the tank with Black Adam or meet him
in one way or another oh that's a great
question I mean you know I always laugh
and joke about Kevin Hart you know Black
Adam and honky Pete and doing things
like that but there's a place for
there's a place for Kevin there's a few
characters who we have in mind I think
there's a place for Idris Elba who's my
boy too as well he could be a badass
superhero there's also super villains
but to your point when you open up that
that DC Bible
dude there are so many uh cool fun
exciting characters to play and I'm just
happy that we at seven bucks we've
gotten to a place now where
um where now we can go we have the key
open up that door and let's go for it
now now and that that's with all due
respect to the Justice League and the IP
and the Legacy that those characters
Batman Superman Wonder Woman flash
Aquaman the Legacy that they have
um but it's time for new blood it's time
for new characters it's time to open up
that bible and time to give it to the
fans I mean the item's already taken so
I know Kevin like I don't know who's
left
there's a character called dog
it's a tiramana talking
thanks man cheers